There's a winner from the war in Ukraine. It's
Qatar. Wait. Qatar, the tiny desert country in
the Persian Gulf that kind of looks like a thumb?
Hear me out. The first thing you need to know is
that Russia actually provides Europe with a ton of
energy through natural gas. They've got these huge
pipelines that feed Europe with natural gas.
Oh, I see where this is going. Let me guess,
something something sanctions. You'll see.
But yes, sanctions. Europe sanctioned Russia's
economy and in retaliation, Russia cut off the
gas that it was sending into Europe, the gas
that they use to heat their homes and cook their
food and stay warm during the winter and like run
their factories. Oh, so Europe can't get its gas
from Russia anymore because of the economic war,
so they're turning to Qatar. Bingo. Qatar has sh*t
tons of natural gas and now Europe is knocking at
their door, being like, “Hey, we need natural
gas.” They don't have any pipelines that they
can just like flip on for Europe. But over the
next few years, they're going to dramatically
ramp up their natural gas production to meet
all of this demand in Europe. Woah, this is
sounding like big money for Qatar. Huge money
for Qatar. It also means a lot more influence.